[Music]
joining me today is the Libertarian
candidate for governor from the great
state of New York Larry sharp welcome to
the Rubin report thanks for having me
libertarian New York yes are you okay
sir the issue to remember here is Cato
actually rated us 50th when it came to
freedom we beat California see we got
you huh we're Bhavana yeah you came you
came here to California to see me yes
because we're better than you when it
comes to tyranny we got you down we got
you you can't beat us so yes this is a
critical piece I'm glad I'm doing this
it's the right answer because imagine
this if I make any impact in New York
what is that save the country it shows
that the impact of this race is so
important that if I can make anything
happen in New York State it will affect
the rest of the nation overnight what
you imagine for a second in my race I
just get 10% that will change how people
think in New York throughout the entire
state it'll force Republicans that
actually have the Republicans Democrats
to be Democrats because now the term
party will have an actual voice so now
when I go to Republicans and I say
you're supposed to be about
small-government
someone will listen want to go Democrats
and say you're supposed to be about
civil liberties someone will listen it
will force them to be better but I'm
gonna go one step further what if I
actually beat the Republican in New York
State that's magical I beat the
Republican New York State politics works
for the first two two parties actually
run everything mm-hmm so Republicans
would officially be knocked out so of
course that we write the rules overnight
of course they were right they were two
rules course if I know that are you
implying that New York State has a
corrupt assembly no come on come on we
rose to office Emily yeah let's be clear
of assembly you're insulting me now most
corrupt yeah so no my point being it
would then allow for third parties to
really exist in New York State and that
again would cross the nation
but imagine if actually one if I
actually win I turn New York State gold
that would change the entire nation
overnight overnight all the Liberty
leaning Republicans Democrats would come
out of the woodwork and like we always
love Larry sharp and they would all job
on board and the Libertarian Party will
become huge overnight this race has the
most impact because it's New York okay
so you are acknowledging this is an
uphill battle it's coming - yes and I
gotta tell you if it was six months ago
I knew I could make impact that 10% I
knew I could get
I knew that six months ago what does a
libertarian usually get in a
gubernatorial race 1% maybe I meant
that's a lot we rarely break 40,000
votes if I don't think I've ever bring
in 2,000 folks what do you think of that
before we go specifically a fantasy
because one of my issues with the
libertarians it's like as a party
there's such disorganization you know
III want to talk a little bit of a guy
about Gary Johnson because I know you
work for him and we're almost his VP
choice which I'm gonna mop but I'm a big
fan yeah we can get into the up to some
of that stuff and I've had him on the
show and I think he's a good person I
think he was just a flawed candidate but
just that the party itself seems to be
extremely disorganized and you know when
they should have these conventions and
it's like naked people and naked guys
but that habit met naked guy I'm sure
he's a great he's a great guy nice guys
but that that as a party there's been a
lot of disorganization here and I guess
that when you're making things about the
individual it's hard to get people to
come together on the collective but what
can you do what do you think that's a
fair diagnosis number one what I just
laid out look it's tough the system is
set up against us right it's up against
us to fail any third party right do you
find any other third parties that are
great no but I'll at least like the idea
yes I'm not on board the green stuff so
I want that everything to I mean a lot
of the third parties collapse because
the system is against them but I say the
same thing always the panacea the
cure-all is victory when we begin to win
people will come up with us on arts on
our team a lot of the people who believe
in us don't join our party because of
that so chicken and egg yeah right the
party isn't awesome because awesome
people aren't flooding to it because the
party isn't awesome yeah therefore
awesome people aren't flooding to it
right it's a chicken an egg so once we
become a real party where people
actually are saying wow these guys can
win so one reasons why I'm bringing
Secretariat right
I'm not jump I'm not jumping ship and
join another party and trying to go on
some other party everybody's libertarian
I'm doing
I want to show people a third party can
have impact and can win and join the
third parties my candidacy is assuming I
do very well doesn't just couple
batarians it helps any third party but
obviously heavily my part it's what I
care about but it will help others also
right so you're right it's a problem of
course it is but all the parties are a
problem
look the Republicans Democrats have
kook's also right they're crazy there's
what about it it's just as so few of us
that I would stand out yeah and what a
scrutiny I mean the things that the
things that politicians who are Democrat
Republicans have said are far worse they
were libertarians have said mm-hmm but
it's whatever that the main that the two
old parties so they get a pass yeah I'm
not mad at it it's the way it is it's a
burden that we have that I've accepted
and I've taken on it's the burden I take
on but here's the glory if I win this
battle my victory is sweeter because I
had all the burdens I'm fine with it is
what it is yeah all right so before we
get into the specifics of New York and
what your libertarian principles aren't
things like that tell me a little bit
about your history because you are
actually born and bred in New York and I
am you've got an interesting history and
we're in the Marines and all sorts of
stuff so it was so god gave me back I'll
give you the short version I'm born in
Manhattan biracial parents in the 60s my
mom gives me up for adoption because she
can't handle the issues of bi racial
issues in her family I'm very lucky I
get adopted very young I think I was six
weeks old by a lovely couple who took me
to the Bronx a German immigrant and her
husband who was an in the Army in
Germany that's how we met her so I
raised in the Bronx from around nine or
ten in that area 11 and at that point my
mother had actually divorced and then
another man who was my actual father who
actually raised me and taught me to be a
man
we moved at Long Island he died when I
was around 12 years old when he passed
there just me and my mom my mom couldn't
handle it
she was really devastated by this her
family was in Germany she was here I was
distant that was a young teenage boy
trying to find my way also when I was 17
I left and join the Marine Corps Jenna
Marine Corps was there for about six
years seven years when I got out my
mother had already collapsed she was
initially addicted to legal drugs and
eventually illegal drugs she was
arrested victim the drug war she was the
prison break the felon
I got her out and tried to put it back
on her feet I tried to help her too she
left the prison with two garbage bags
that was what her life was so I helped
her get back on her feet try to get a
job I saw how hard it was for to get a
job I mean she was always lying on every
form because of the knew she was a
felony wouldn't hire her and when she
was working she had to always lie and
she was a hostage basically I became an
entrepreneur because I did my mom to be
a hostage so we set her own business me
and her and my stepdad who was another
man she she had married afterwards and
so we stopped to start a business
together so that she could be her own
person and not be a hostage no that was
our first business after that got up and
running I left that had a bunch of sales
jobs and then decided to then decided to
sell my own business again that business
did not go well I sold that one off then
I went and got this business which I've
had for 14 years I'm a consultant a
trainer I've been an officer in public
company twice I've taught in colleges I
teach now at Baruch sometimes John J
I've taught that at the graduate level
of as a guest instructor and Yale in
Colombia
so I've taught a lot I do a lot of is
like the coaching training leadership
sales that kind of stuff I'm an
entrepreneur benefits of 14 years and
two years ago I saw an opportunity to
jump on board Libertarian Party as a VP
nominee so I tried to get the VP slot
I lost the bill well by 30 31 votes
nothing was counting yeah and now I'm
running for governor that was two years
ago where that was in 2012 2016 that was
2016 1 here's what was why I first came
to the party okay I was not I was not
really political at all when I was uh
when I was a youngster do you wanna hear
this story yeah when I'm a young I'm
interviewing you all right I love
anything we're doing I'm happy too yep
away 90 me out I know the first time
anyone's ever said that to me I love you
wanna hear all these ones me and my cool
stuff I don't want to guess Yap away and
they're like you know clicking off I'm
going to watch I don't have a drink
instead what do you wanna do if that
would make it better maybe all right
let's see what the story so as a
youngster I grew up in New York City and
of course Democrats are good and
publicans are evil how it works right
you're evil because you're gonna are by
your name you're good because you vide
by your name yeah who is the mayor at
the time this is really I think it was
Ed Koch Ed Koch okay I love dead Koch
although I grew up in Long
but we were big family but it wasn't
about him it was about the party yeah my
mom and dad were strict Democrats that's
who you are
you were a Democrat because they were
good and Poppins were evil yeah but when
I joined the Marine Corps at 17 the
Marine Corps is a very conservative
branch when it comes to the branches and
most of my friends and people had no and
leaders that I respected they were
mostly conservative Republicans Ronald
Reagan was my first commander-in-chief
so I think I kind of became a Republican
as a as a teen and as a young
20-something I became over Republican so
I kind of shape the back I wasn't part
of a party and I only voted in the
presidential elections because it was
absentee I wasn't I was also Versys so I
voted be a male so I didn't even
register locally to do the local
elections yeah so we pause everyone to
act because so you mentioned you're
biracial yeah and I hate making anything
about race because we're so overly
racialized now and identity politics and
all this but I think that a certain
amount of my own is when they hear you
say that all right so you were you were
Ronald Reagan was your
commander-in-chief and you were
identifying as a Republican back then as
a black man yeah you know I've had many
black conservatives on here some of whom
I consider great friends like Larry
elder and I bet this is Thomas olan and
many or no so that's why I wanted to ask
you about that yeah what was it like
then to take that political it wasn't
very political if that made any sense I
wasn't talking about things I did but
other than internally for you I didn't
care to be 40 I didn't care if you I
don't care now I didn't get her then and
over here now yeah I am Who I am I
believe what I believe and you like it
or you don't and that's how is it didn't
care that either right on man so I
didn't really care to be folk with you
some people thought I was crazy
my parents Rob with insane whatever I
didn't care I didn't talk about it much
it wasn't I was worried about you know
chasing girls and it's 19 20 years old
being a marine I was I wasn't worried
about it it wasn't part of my life to
before with you I I look back now I wish
it was I wish I had known more stuff
then but I was a young guy trying to
figure out to be a man I wasn't really
thinking about that very much so that's
why eventually in the 90s I went to I
went to Peru because I just didn't want
the arse of the DS then I went to NATO
in 2000 because I didn't want the arse
of the DS I knew that the arse and the
DS were the same there was a difference
ideally all putting my friends in jail I
knew they were all the war on drugs and
the war on terror wasn't gonna stop
that's that was gonna be bad no matter
what I did
excuse me so I just and again if you
would have asked me what was Perot what
was it what was Nate errs policies I
couldn't have told you I just knew they
weren't the mainstream and therefore
they were good enough for me and again
people thought I was crazy I didn't care
so finally in 2008 I was considering not
bullying all anymore I was really
finished I was like who cares it doesn't
matter of growing a business I'm gonna
run my business make my money become a
bazillionaire and who cares who's in
charge
cuz I'll run them cuz I'll have all the
money that was my logic it doesn't for
ya so but doesn't eight when Obama came
I thought okay this is different he's a
city guy he's black this is the guy he's
different he speaks differently people
are excited alright you know what maybe
this is the guy night I had hope I
bought the hope and change I bought it
mm-hmm and when I joined before you
added sort of a libertarian awakening
right actually I I this I was having
libertarian awakening but that sort of
overrode it but I gotta tell you how I
became there yeah I became looat Arian
not through politics
I came them training through Robert
ringer do you know Robert ringer I don't
think Robert ringer is a business guy
he's Objectivist and he had brought many
books looking out for number one to be
or not to be intimidated nothing happens
unless something moves action he talks
about how to brand yourself he talks
about how to be successful in business
in life I was a trainer that's what I
said to now he was one of my you know
mentors I don't know in person but I
read his books I was part of his website
so I knew who he was so he got me into
reading and rent I didn't come to
libertarianism through politics I came
in through business I'm a business guy
huh so I was reading Atlas Shrugged
because he said we got the shrugged not
because some political guy did I didn't
know who Ron Paul was doesn't eight I
had no idea I wasn't political I was a
business guy yeah the reason why I care
about Obama's because he was so
different it got my attention so again I
did really understand his policies if
that made me sense yeah I just thought
he's different he's not them it can't be
worse that was my thought process so as
I'm moving towards objectivism in that
regard I'm not an Objectivist and I
never been
but some of the market ideas made sense
to me the idea of Austrian economics
made sense to me I didn't know was
Austrian economics though cuz I never
read Friedman I never read those I
didn't know I read brought a ringer yeah
and he had told me what his his views so
I gotta think secondhand through him so
I was already teaching I was teaching
post-industrial internship obviously
she'd buy-in I was teaching sales is not
about forcing someone to do something
getting to do it I was teaching
volunteerism not knowing what it was
called or what it was I was already
doing it in my own business so anyway I
was I was having that change three dozen
Ford about 2010 anyway that was
happening already I'm so it changed my
business model and doing it already
after crash hit I had to jump into it a
lot cuz I was crushed in it scratch
scratch devastated me so anyway III
think Obama's great after the first year
I realized he's no different again I'm
finished I'm like it's over
until 2012 I hear Gary Johnson speak and
people say well Gary Taubes he's an
awesome speaker no but he was a business
guy I'm a business guy I could hear him
I couldn't hear anyone else cuz I didn't
care I could only hear the person who I
was identified with him self-made man
growing a business I identify with Gary
Johnson I still do and so when he
decided to talk I said oh I get it and I
came to the part because of him but to
be forward I didn't join the party still
right away I've never done a partner mat
in my life I never joined a party but at
this point I thought you know what I'm
gonna go to the meetings and never been
to a party meeting before and I went to
the meetings and when I went to
Libertarian Party meetings as odd as
they were and they are odd it was still
just regular people
it wasn't crazy there was regular people
business owners people who wondered see
some change I identified it quickly with
them and I joined so I joined the party
in 2012 and that's when I became a
libertarian yeah but when I joined the
party I hadn't read Basquiat I hadn't
read for I didn't read any of them and I
didn't even know them so that's when I
joined them I began looking around and
then I read the law - my favorite of all
them was bossy is my favorite that was
the simplest and the one that identified
with the most
still my favorite but I read all the
rest also I began to read them right I
read the word Road to Serfdom I began to
read those afterwards but they were easy
for me to understand the people they
teasing a Larry you've been in the
movement so short so hard but you can
you can talk with the principles I've
been teaching them for 14 years
yeah but not under the name right in a
different world so it was very easy to
me to adapt and to bring those those
things to bear so I've order for Gary
Johnston 2012 and I support his
candidacy completely in 2016
I was running around doing debates in
his stead that was on TV instead for him
and they wanted I would do so I jump
through hoops for him because I I wish
it was a president now yeah I wish she
was so I don't want to belabor the point
Gary I voted for Gary I did I did a
video in the summer before the election
of why it would be great to support him
he wasn't a perfect handed etc etc but
he he had a couple gaffes that were
pretty bad and I also I don't even blame
him for them in a certain way because it
was the only 2-year point it was the
only way he could get press like the
only time they talked about him yes was
aleppo apps or the other moment where he
couldn't name a leader that he respected
but the one the one policy point that
really bothered me with him and I don't
know maybe maybe we don't see eye to eye
on this is that he wanted the the Baker
to bake the cake well let me touch two
of those things yes the first thing is
every problem that Gary Johnson had is
fixed with good advisers everyone yeah
repaired with good advisers yeah every
problem he had you get him good advisors
fixed yeah Clinton and Trump I don't
care who you put one of them it's
irrelevant who do you put whatever team
you put it for them they have character
flaws mmm Johnson doesn't have that so
you're right as a human being you I mean
yes I'll have to tell you but I mean I
sat there with him for an hour and some
time off camera and I thought this is a
decent human kind of a second yes I'm
with you so if I had a choice I'd rather
than be president now without question
of course yeah
but the second base debate the cake he
didn't do a good job explaining what he
really meant and I let me try to explain
it to make it clearer
he understood the cultural aspects of
this as do i as a person of color Yeah
right there is a we've had literally
decades if not centuries of state spa
answered segregation punishment by
gender by by by race by by sexual
preference that is still in the psyche
of the American it feels terrible to do
what is right if that makes any sense
yeah it feels terrible and while the
person goes but it's wrong
I get it emotion and culture matter and
what he was trying to get out which is
my policy it was to find a good solid
middle ground I do not want a baker to
make a cake for someone he doesn't want
make a cake for that's his labor having
to do for someone that's wrong should
never happen so here is the here is the
good compromise yeah
if a baker or anyone anyone creates a
product and puts it into the retail
market whether it be online or on a
shelf in a store if a person creates a
product and puts it there
he must allow anyone who has the
currents that he wants to purchase that
product so far yeah I'm with you so far
now that you could say and and purist
will say no Larry he can say no to
anyone so that would be the set of
people who would like to go back and
reverse this 64 Civil Liberties act yes
I'm saying just let now if the person is
I want that cake off the shelf and
literally you're Jewish and he's a Nazi
with a swastika on his arm you must say
take it you've the money to take my
ticket out of here so that he hold on he
then says I now want you to put on it so
and so no you can refuse that service
because now that's not retail mm-hmm
that's you doing a service for that
individual you should absolutely say no
I will not put anything on that cake at
all that's the way it is that's why I
made it for anyone if you want it take
it that's not good enough for you have a
nice day that is my compromise and I
think that's what Garry Johnson actually
meant to say because if you're heard the
way he said it and when I spoke to him
out of here this is what I was saying
then I wish yes I'm with you honor what
you just said yes I'm with you I'm sure
and I want it I try to defend him with
that but it didn't come across right and
I think he did and it because for him to
be fold I'm gonna defend him
and defend them often yeah it's
emotional for him so didn't come across
well mm-hmm so mostly for me too but I
know what it's like I know personally
it's like to be to be ignored in a
restaurant I know what that's like
glad you don't it feels terrible
now to be forward I think that's a good
compromise
okay so I'm with you on that I'm glad
you cleaned it up for yourself and I'm
glad you cleaned it up for Gary because
I feel kind of cuz I know he's a decent
guy and I don't like giving him crap for
it what would you say to the part of the
libertarians that want to go that extra
step that say either the 64 Act should
be repealed because we don't need these
laws anymore or that no you just even if
it's just the same old product on your
shelf and you just don't like the way
somebody looks because you are a bigot
it's still your stuff and then what do
you say they are theoretically correct
and realistically wrong and if they
don't accept the compromise they're
going to get worse this is the problem
that a lot of the more hard libertarians
donors that very clear I love them I
want them in the party they are critical
they are the backbone of the party there
are our harshest and most powerful
activists we need them yeah and you
believe that that's not based in bigotry
that's at all yeah now that's an at all
but that's an amount indistinct it's
based on righteousness and they're right
the problem is if you don't take that
first step you will get nothing but not
just nothing those people who keep
voting are gonna keep voting our rights
away they do it every single year they
keep voting our rights away as we accept
everything or nothing it is it nothing
it's worse it's worse
give us the compromise that makes sense
they'll see the world doesn't end
they'll see this not a zombie apocalypse
and then we can move the next level yeah
is that part of the problem of being
sort of an outlier party because the
Libertarian Party that's existed for a
long time and it's in on all the ballots
but never really breaks any major
thresholds that part of it is you get
too caught up in the purity test now all
parties do in a way what though but I
think for the third parties it may be a
little trickier and maybe for
libertarians more than
because if you're really basing it on
the individual the purity test is pretty
freakin high is what you're gonna make
very clear you look at Democrat
Republicans now they're not actually
parties they're tribes and I mean that
literally they're tribes
you have whoever is the the king of the
tribe at the moment the will of the king
is the platform right
so whatever Trump says that's the
platform right assuming that Bernie's
still top of the Democrats on top he is
whoever is right yeah
then that's the platform whoever the
person is that's the platform the
platform is whoever is on top of the
party which is why they don't argue as
much which is why they close ranks right
so easily
the Libertarian Party is different it
actually has an ideology I can call
myself king of libertarians if I want to
that's not gonna go well at all and no
one's gonna buy it that's not gonna work
you want to change that language yes sir
that is not gonna work at all yeah I can
say it if I want to so what I'll get
laughs out of the party yeah because
it's not about me it's about audiology
which is why we are you to be forward
with you I'm happy we argue I am because
it makes us a better party it makes us
clear it actually it's policy easier for
us because we don't look at piles of
that oh this policy fits this no it's
based about the based upon audiology so
I'm actually happy that we argue I wish
you didn't argue so much as well
publicly right that's the part of drives
me crazy that we do it so publicly right
and that we fight so hard but I'm glad
we have an idea yeah
again I don't know that it's that you
guys are doing it so publicly it's just
that that's the only time that you're
seen in public it's a bit of an
important distinction so when you say
that the way you just described the cake
situation is basically your view on
government in general because again this
is where you can go to a libertarian
that really is an ad cap or the people
you describe is the backbone that it
basically you're sort of I guess I would
just I mean this is what I would say a
classical liberal is really it's just
that where the rubber meets the road you
understand that there has to be some
level of government is that sort of your
guiding principle look my my North Star
is a full voluntary society that's my
North Star I would love to have a total
and fully voluntary society how do you
define what that is where
where government is even voluntary that
would be amazing but to be four with you
our nation is nowhere near I mean that's
I Martha asked me what I'd you know I'd
like I'd like a world with leprechauns
ride unicorns yeah at the moment it's
the same thing it just doesn't exist
yeah it's we're nowhere near there and
one reason why I'm attacking New York
State as as hard as I am campaigning so
hard is if we can just stop the bleeding
if we can just stop it from shifting
left right now if you know we're talking
in New York State about giving teachers
the right to tell law enforcement if a
child is dangerous so they can now
confiscate that child's parents guns
we're talking about that now that's the
new times on New York State we're just
we're going so far away it's not even
funny so to talk about this it's
imaginary I just want to turn around let
me do that if I do that we got a shot to
get in there I probably will never see a
voluntary Society in my life I probably
won't
it'd be awesome if I could but can I
turn us around so we're facing it at
least that I can do yeah that I can
absolutely do and I do it in my lifetime
I can do it in New York State and go in
the country we can do that
yeah so with that in mind when you talk
about the principles of the party how do
you generally decide what the right
amount of government is then I mean
you're want you want to be in the
government so the government has to do
something is it really just on a
case-by-case basis of what's the light
is such it's always okay deep I don't
have you ever run for office not yeah
all right one of the reasons why it's so
hard there's many reasons why one is
raising money opposite them it's time
but the third one is understanding all
the policies and when you begin to
understand how much government intrudes
in our life it's depressing and I mean
that truly most people have no idea how
much government intrudes in her life and
how much it actually hurts it's
depressing
I have policy calls every my policy team
we on the phone use anywhere from an
hour to two hours every weekend
discussing policy issues sometimes I'm
depressed when I'm done because it's
bad there's no good answer because
government problem has been solved with
government bandaid which has been solved
by government band-aid so if he pull off
government band-aid
you've three more broken band-aids
underneath it that sometimes make things
worse hmm sometimes breaking government
off makes it worse because of three more
band-aids that are all terrible some
Mudgett they just say I can't touch that
I just have to let it stay there and you
have someone who goes but Lowrey that's
wrong they're righteous that's ear we
have to stop it there are three thousand
things I have to fix some I just can't
put on my radar so yes it's always case
by god to try to fix government is a
Herculean task that no one could do yeah
what do you make of the states like New
York that have gotten so away from the
ideas forget the policies forget the
three set thousand problems right but
just the basic ideas of why Liberty and
individualism and limited government and
your own capacity to control your
property and things of that nature
the states that have gotten so far away
from that I mean that's I guess that's
why you're running in the first yeah its
culture people ask all the time they see
a line you know what are your first hard
day's gonna be like and what are you
gonna change they think I'm gonna walk
into New York State as governor and wave
my magic wand oh yeah bring up my gun
the King now everything changes of
course not I wouldn't want to if I could
right I can't and I wouldn't want to if
I could that kind of fast change makes
people afraid and here's the reason to
be clear it's all about fear when people
are afraid they make bad decisions
that's simply human nature fear makes
bad decisions
fear is the root of aggression
government the end of it is law at the
end of every law there's a couple minor
exceptions but almost every law the end
of everyone is a guy or a gal with a gun
to put you in a cage which means by
default law is force government is force
now should we never use force no no you
can use force defend your rights
properly you can use force but when you
are afraid your first step is force
when you are afraid your first step is
government and that's what happens in
the states like New York California the
first answer is government is filled
there ought to be a law yeah I don't
like this there won't be a law this is
wrong there were to be a law and that
culture has been part of us for at least
50 years if not more I mean just decades
upon decades it's been that way I see
the same thing right Oh someone smoking
in front of me there would be a long
race you think the same way until I was
enlightening goal oh no that's a bad
idea why would I do that
you know what I thought I was righteous
and that thing that we have to remember
is we also idealize the idea of
democracy we idolize when we voted
there's a law the story I love I tell
this whole time I was speaking to an IP
attorney in Fletcher property attorney
and she was talking about intellectual
property law and I'm making this up I
don't remember the actual rules so she
said something and again I'm not a
lawyer I'm gonna just say numbers so we
have some you know after copyright law
is you know 95 years after the person's
death it was something like that and I
said 95 years at their death yeah I said
what a terrible law it's horrible
she said yeah Larry but it's the law I
know I'm not doubting that you're a
lawyer I'm sure you know the law I'm
sure that's true and it's a bad law she
said but Larry understand we had to
change our laws to match international
law so now we match international law
and I said great that's a really bad
international law she looked like she
was angry at me yeah because in her eyes
law equals righteousness the same
there's no difference international law
equals extra righteousness it's just
it's amazing yeah so she was mad at me
because in her eyes I was a heretic
that's how she saw me now she didn't
make the law it wasn't her idea she was
not Congress person who did it no she's
simply a priest of the law and I'm a
heretic and she was mad at me name I
think well that's only lawyers guide
Department buildings in New York I'm
talking to him guys educated smart
credentialed they say to him I say I'm
kind of curious about the landmarking
law and if you may not know
New York City is when you can actually
you know kind of a community can say
this property's landmark and now nothing
can be done to that property unless the
community agrees lots of people want it
they want to protect their community so
they can't developers can't come in and
go all the time is that just for a
building or is that for actually for can
it be for like a group of buildings or a
part of things I think it's one but they
out of time
okay I'm pretty sure it's one property
at a time okay but I'm sorry doing
groups but I think it's one property to
time yeah so you can also have that
happen to you without you wanting the
community can just landmark your
property that can happen and that has
happen a couple times so now the
community landmarks your property so I
totally I said how is that okay I don't
understand that works and the guy tell
me Larry it's the same lower use who
when that building is condemned and
that's wrong that that makes sense right
condemning makes sense if a building
collapses thousands could die totally
makes sense I see a victim got that law
I'm in good when it comes a landmarking
where's dictum here at none allow you
understand it's the same law we use okay
I said I get that totally get it yeah
where's the victim latter it's the same
law because in his eyes again law knee
cools righteousness this is the mindset
we have in for many Americans and we
have to break that mindset the idea that
just because the law doesn't make it
right just by default lots of laws have
been bad and been overturned and are
wrong lots of them are law doesn't make
it regice but we say well we voted now
it becomes okay now great I vote you
give me all yourself
awesome I guess you'll be merry stuff
now you can't have all my stuff yeah
well there we go but I voted so we got a
problem I try to tell people when I go
through New York State I'm trying to
change the concept of government right
now government most of the time is just
this it enforces the will of the
majority
I want government's primary purpose to
be to instead defend the rights of the
individual specifically when you have
localization from the local bullies who
will pop up because local bullies will
always pop up but now local bullies are
validated by the big government because
you voted so local bullies have more
power than ever
instead the state government should be
defending the individual
against local bullies against eminent
domain against property rate tax hikes
against speeding tickets at our four
hundred five dollars for speeding ticket
it's been defending them against the
local bullies but we're not alright so
let's talk about some of the unique
issues in New York because although a
lot of states have you know a big city
and then a rural area New York really
has it and I remember growing up in New
York where there were always you know
I'd read Newsday was the long island
paper and they were always talking about
the fights between New York City and
Albany because we have this huge rural
upstate area the Upstate area right now
is extremely economically depressed
absolutely I went to SUNY Binghamton I I
know the area pretty well how do you
deal with someone that wants to be the
governor of the state the jump executor
of the state how do you deal with having
what is it something around like 8
million people Aden half million people
in New York City 16 million in metro
area if you includes parts of
Connecticut poly Jersey Long Island
parts of Westchester County so it's
about 16 million metro area it's New
York City is the largest city in America
yeah and by far it's been over double La
La's a second and it's over double yeah
so it is by far our largest city in
America there are more people in one of
our boroughs than at least ten states
mm-hmm just one of our girls there are
more people in New York City than are in
40 states that's how big we are we're
massive there are there are but not just
that New York City is very unique in
that about one third of its population
is not born in the country and another
about one third is not born in in the in
the city so we are literally a magnet
for talent mm-hmm which is why because
we were a magnet for talent and we have
16 million people who are possible
candidates for you know customers
candidates for four jobs we can
basically be a communist state and still
function right because we have so many
advantages our our advantages are so
high yeah it's people say how can you
possibly work in New York City there's
so many advantages and we have the
massive advantage of Finance I mean
finance is a massive part of New York
State Manhattan's infrastructure is huge
so basically the Machine just keeps
churning that threat through people
through jobs through everything else so
the more ways the more you push out the
more you bring in absolutely so the so
it just keeps happening
yeah the rest of New York State is not
the way at all that's the New York
Central New York northern in a northern
country southern tier Long Island very
different no different and one of the
things I'm doing is I'm trying to show
them something very important this has
to come down to localization it's making
government smaller in general right Neal
says several problems as you talked
about the city from the rest which is
very different but also 70% of New
Yorkers don't vote in certain counties
upstate only one in seven vote they've
given up they've just given up it's
learned helplessness yeah right they
just totally given up and we have over a
hundred thousand New Yorkers leaving our
state every single year over hundred
thousand but a million in last eight
years walking away now you said my god
and walking away New York City must be
getting killed no New York sees
population same or higher yeah all
coming from upstate western New York all
coming from the land leaving its youth
flight all our young people are getting
educated leaving or leaving in educating
someplace else not coming back yeah it's
not mostly a tax issue I'm sorry is that
mostly a tax issue my job is everything
it's high cost of living uh no
opportunities those who things combined
but it can't change because we have a
thing called unfunded mandates and it is
devastating our state and what does that
mean that means in a given County up to
95 sometimes over a hundred percent of
the budget is already mandated by Albany
our capital o by DC so who's running the
county someone else's why show up we
have local cities and towns where we
will have enough people to fill all the
billets four people show up ok guess
you're the chair I'm the vice chair
yours I'm Terry because we're here mmm
right and no one else shows up ever
unless they're angry so angry will show
up against them it by default becomes us
versus them they go in their back room
create their ethics and announce the
people and we have local tyrants but
more importantly how do I can think that
in my County when I have to buy all
these things and as mandated by the
state and by the federal government
I have to raise money somehow only two
ways there's a loophole in New York
State when it comes to property taxes
every the tax has to be voted on by the
people property tax no only by counsel
so officially our government will tell
you there's a two
cap in property tax mmm but there's an
exception if it's an emergency so they
go by and closed doors declare emergency
and raise property taxes nine percent
what are they count as an emergency I
need money
we have enough money the unfunded
mandates go past our budget so two
choices option one is that property
taxes option two you use law enforcement
as a profit Center so now that that part
you think that was a hundred bucks is
not there in a box speeding ticket that
was 50 bucks is now five hundred bucks
it's so bad that a lot of places in New
York State they don't even want you to
come to court anymore
so when you get a bunch of tickets they
ads just sell the tickets off to collect
agency get thirty cents of a dollar and
everyone your credit because they don't
wanna waste your time bring you in for
court because you might not be able to
pick they don't care if you pay yeah
they're actually ting the money from the
klephts agency so they get a bunch of
tickets clients agency gets it you you
go to court whenever you want with them
so okay so hearing everything you just
said there it's if that's like one of
those things maybe that it makes so much
sense it shows what the glut is the the
middle-management corruption and greed
and all that so I'm not even close but
it's not no no I know but let's just
pause go ahead no cuz because as you're
saying it I'm thinking man this is the
type of stuff that I think if people
really understood they would be pissed
about but it's like one of those things
that as a candidate explaining this to
people and getting people to be like yes
it is the backdoor deals this is like
one of those issues where it's not easy
to put the bumper sticker on and get
people to get excited about it's not I
need to build that wall any whatever
that's right exactly now to build that
wall yeah yeah exactly yeah and my so
far I'm using a new New York and save
Main Street I mean working pretty well
you know I had a couple of those sayings
we're seeing which one actually lands
we're using those right now seeing how
they work but yeah I mean this is a big
problem I self core people don't show up
cause a little vote nothing changes
right but here's another problem we have
counties where you have one-third of the
population of Medicaid one-third on
Medicare and a dwindling population the
tax burden wearing up New York State has
a budget of about one hundred and
seventy billion dollars and compared to
California I'm sure however I'm gonna
I'm gonna I'm gonna compare that to
other state Florida Florida has more
people than us half the budget now the
the only one I always get is
but Larry New Yorkers expect their set-
services then why are hundred thought I
was leaving every year and half of them
are going to Florida so many New Yorkers
are leaving our state that in the
Carolinas they have a name for us they
call it half backs Florida and half way
back so when the Carolinas will go hat
back yes that's how common it is now
we're running about every time I do an
event I ask two questions question
number one I say how many people here I
think might live in New York hands
always go up and they look around laughs
there's only one no half the room in
every place I go I go to a college they
go to a diner I go to a VFW this matter
where I go I got American Legion I go
someplace boom half the hands go up
they're all ready to leave most of us
somehow trapped trapped because of kids
trapped because of job traffickers their
properties in the water the tract yeah
but as soon as they can get that next
level
they are gone huge problem secondly I
asked all time is how many of you have
not voted in the past two election
cycles hands always the one what does
that mean it means I'm drawing the
people in because what about the most
important piece here and that is what
about impact what to do how do I win
this thing
this is a winnable race six months ago I
wouldn't have said that now I know this
is at least a four person race it's
gonna be his Majesty King Cuomo he will
be running for sure the Communists Howie
Hawkins run for the winning party the
sacrificial lamb we run for Republicans
who cannot win just fighting for second
place who is very Molinaro okay he's a
downstate Republican they picked two
downstate Republicans to run for
governor and the governor clearly gage
surrendered yeah let's just get as much
as we can from New York City and try to
get second place they've surrendered and
then me at least four it's possible the
actor from Sex in the City Nixon will
stay in maybe I don't know if she will
after she loses to Cromwell she may stay
and I may not so - maybe
and then maybe someone else a miner out
of Syracuse mayor has independent it's
possible curve six but at least for New
York state's a plurality state means all
I need is more than the rest there are
about 18 million 19 million New Yorkers
about 12 men will vote only about 4 to 5
million every vote 1.5 million votes on
the governor 30% I'm the governor Larry
that's huge it is
but Gary John's got a hundred
seventy-five thousand votes in my state
in 2016 he was there for five minutes he
showed up waved and walked away and
there was a hundred thirty five thousand
people who said I'm so sick and tired
I'll vote for Gary Johnson I'll do it
I'll do it I'll do it
I live in the state I campaign mistake
I've raised more money than everyone
except for the governor you tell me I
can't get ten times that five times that
even of course I can but more
importantly do three have to clap to get
three types number one I'm happy
Democrat Republicans tons of that no
shortage but they're not my number one
because many of them will still go back
to old ways because most people who vote
often usually vote because of fear not
because of hope they're slow fraidy
other guy might win there most of them
as didn't go back to old ways I get that
but some of them are I'll take whatever
I get but the next one is the single
issue voter the person who cares about
only one thing and one thing only I
bring up many of these issues of the
vaping industry right in New York State
it's gonna crush the vaping industry I
don't know why they can't stand it
trying to destroy baby industry silly
why would you well if you're a vapor
that's important if your own of you own
a vape shop that's your livelihood I
could be saying I want to support my
ministry and kick puppies in the streets
the public care about yeah it's it it's
all yeah so it issues like that right
people who father's right people have
been crushed by family law I have an
entire policy for fixing the family
court system has been completely
revamped their fathers at least a
million who've been crushed and
destroyed by the family court system in
New York State I mean didn't devastate
it they have higher suicide rates
they've been their families they're in
jail horribleness right these people
care about that issue I will fix time in
law I'm the only one sporting event
industry
going with my family law these people
vote for me because that's what they
care about people who know state who've
gotten DUIs three duis or more and they
lose your license in perpetuity no
matter what there are some people who've
paid the time in jail
done parole and have been clean for five
years clean you've straighten your life
out you've done your time you've paid
your time in jail and you brawl in every
license back yeah and if they leave New
York State then the other state won't
get my license was revoked they may
never drive again yeah you're not giving
a chance to be a functioning memory kid
that has to go and people say but Larry
why would you support these industries
well number one of these issues why it's
right I'm libertarian that's what we do
I am righteous of course I am
libertarians always and it's the thing
most of them don't get libertarians
always have the moral high ground always
they act like we don't but we always do
I know that so I take the moral high
ground it's mine I own it so I take it
and it's right I'm in a pocket of big
DUI I'm not popular a big paper of
course not yeah right it shows people
that I care that it makes sense and they
know that when I get into power I'm
still gonna support these people I'm not
going I'm not in it for the money yeah
these people vote tons of these issues
they will jump on board and they will
vote but more than that
there are eight million New Yorkers who
don't vote they vote because of hope
Bernie taught us this and Trump told us
this trump game gave the right hope
Bernie gave the left help now if the
Democratic Party wasn't so broken Bernie
would have been the nominee and it
woulda been hope versus hope and hope
one I think you mean corrupt yes I don't
know if it's be nor corrupt is
intentional outcomes they were both yeah
but it would have been hell purses hope
hope one yeah hope gets people out of
their bed stop playing video games you
show up how do you make that happen by
having events I'm doing events all the
time people are showing up to my events
who didn't vote which means they will
show up at the polling booth trumpet
brain told us this I'm copying them it's
working look look what got you here I
mean your guys I started seeing it more
and more and more on Twitter next thing
I know I think you tweeted at me or one
of your guys tweeted at me and we made
it happen
absolutely I love Cuomo on yes guess
what but here's the next four pieces now
now if I just get 10% of the eight
million eight hundred thousand I'm
halfway there tell us what I'll pick up
I'm the governor I get 20% it's a blow
out this is a winnable race there were
four arenas anyone who has to win on to
get elected four first ones social media
six months ago go I could never win
because Cuomo has so much more money
than I have right I don't know where it
went but he's hos media's incompetent we
are winning on social media tomorrow and
this is proof of it we are killing in
social media we are winning hands down
but that's just one the second one a
traditional media this one I struggling
it's tough for me they go for the
popular Cynthia Nixon is popular or the
governor they go with the tried and true
it's very hard to get it and I live in
New York City New York City something's
always going on tough to get coverage so
to get around that at the going upstate
western New York small towns where they
have two choices right some some guy
lost his cow or Irish upcoming town so
I've been doing that so you got a lot of
local media but I've also learned that
local media also often overlaps they
also have such Peter presents some of
the writers are shared among different
papers so I'm getting a lot of press in
the local paper so I'm doing better to a
tional media I don't know if I can
actually win it maybe maybe not but
that's one that's one issue that I'm
fighting on I'm trying new tactics to
win on that one the next one's events as
I talked about right now no one else is
doing events I'm the only one doing them
the only went out shaking hands and
kissing babies and meeting people and
I'm winning events like there's no
tomorrow
I'm winning in events right now the
issue is they will eventually begin
doing events so when they do will I will
I have ramped up to speed or not some
questionable on those two the last ones
debates if you see me debate I have no
problem debating I will crush them on
debates so I will win social media and
debates the question is can I win
traditional media and our events if I
win three out of four on the governor
now you said you said a key if there
which was if you Bates what's the debate
situation know the odds are only relates
because traditionally for always in the
dates they were in 2014 2010
traditionally are to be libertarian
Green Democrat Republican so mods are of
in debates odds are very high then they
keep you in the debate regardless of
polling and for that one one Syrian it's
for all the way across but they probably
only do what to 2 or 3 they do one
debate only oh that's why a bait in
October one in October it's all man so
that's like that's like the show up and
that's it we move the drawer right there
yeah I don't wanna I like the odds like
that it's a good odds what kind of
support are you getting from the party
itself Oh as good as it can be I mean
look it's New York State libertarians
aren't that many of them too small party
there are 62 counties in New York we
have about 20 affiliates so we have 42
counties I mean have affiliates so it's
it's not a powerful party across the
state we're not even officially a party
we're officially a committee
what yes but I'm the the the party's on
him set behind me a hundred percent
mm-hmm
there isn't that much there what they
can do they are doing I'm very happy
with what they're doing I wish I'd pick
a party I wish had more bodies I do I
wish I had more bodies but luckily again
there we are and we're getting more
people from the states are coming also
other people are joining and for the
first time now people that are coming to
the party because of me right
most people who join me before came to
the party because of someone else Ron
Paul Gary Johnson Harry Brown and then
so my candidacy yeah jump on board but
now that I've been so active for so many
months in New York State some people are
now coming to party because of me those
people are now building up our group of
of activists so I am getting more and
more again what I'm getting from the
people is amazing
I do any more of them though so we are
getting there do you sense that there is
a rebirth of Liberty in this country in
general I mean I can tell from when I'm
out now on the road and touring and the
response I get to this show and the
amount of emails I get in Twitter that
people are talking about Liberty again
they're talking about it's not just the
Tea Party anymore talking about Liberty
talk about Liberty you talk about
freedom you talk about the the founding
documents people are actually
reinvigorated about this stuff what most
people is two things one they feel like
things are so broken and then too
someone gives them hope revolutions as
they say install was it built on hope
they are it's true right the the
Russians stayed about 300 years being
oppressed whatever it was foreign ears
being oppressed as peasants and serfs
and so there was some hope then the
Communists gave them hope you know and
they revolted it has to be hope but it
wasn't a communist communism had been
around for a bit
it was Lenin right it was individual
people bring people to revolutions
people give other people hope we're
finding better messengers now that we've
ever had yeah it's not just Rob all
right it's a lot of us are doing this
and I'm hoping if you've seen my
campaign I'm doing my best half of my
team is not in New York
that's one purpose is that right that's
our purpose because I want to make sure
that my seven directors and about 50
active volunteers and about two hundred
and wings and I'm purposely doing that
because I want people to be able to
grow that infrastructure so that in 2020
we have seven campaign managers active
campaign who run a real campaign who not
do things like this who not make things
work
the betrayin party does not have an
infrastructure we need it if we have
better infrastructure we have more
people like me who want to do this right
people don't run because they have to
run by themselves so infrastructure yeah
but now I can say no here's your team
better people will run and they'll run
better candidacies they'll run better
campaigns and when they do that more
people will see them will bring more
people to the movement I think there is
a rise but it's because we're having
better candidates yeah are you tracking
Austin Peterson out in Missouri I'm a
fan I have he's been here with more
friends I think he's doing great work
last I saw a poll just in the last
couple weeks I mean it looks like he's
beaten McCaskill III think that's one of
the type of ones and Ben potentially
yours as well that I agree with you in
that for sure that it's like man if one
of these guys breaks through I just wish
he'd put an L by his name so I think he
had well I think he you know he
definitely is a libertarian there's no
doubt about that I think yeah yes yeah
doing forward I'm one record I was I was
probably the only guy on it on the in
The Libertines leadership who said
please stay yeah I openly what I call
about one mistake I wanted him to stay
and what did what did he say to that
he's just real politic Joe bothers don't
Ruth he's like look everyone's tell me
go above him you like you like one of
the only guys tell me to go a
libertarian yeah I was one of the only
guys it's true so at the end of the day
I still wanted to be little charity but
at the end of the day you still want him
to win of course yeah clearly yes yes of
course I want to win
yes yeah well I'd rather have him on
McCaskill and Senate it's not even close
I mean there's not even close of course
not of course I don't know I don't
McCaskill oh of course of course I
wanted to win yes I'm just saying I look
I'm selfish I'd rather have an L by his
name yeah but I'll take him inaros a
little bow deal I'll deal with the
manaro say so I'll tell you one of my
fears about what could potentially
happen with the labor Karen's because I
do you can see I'm with you on so much
of this stuff and even though again as I
call myself a classical liberal there's
plenty of room for agreement here okay
great and and where there is where there
might be little disagreement
that's that's rich right that's a great
place to do it okay what I'm a little
concerned about is that the movement of
Liberty is going to grow and grow and
grow
it's gonna do real nice you'll probably
do pretty well if not when you'll do
pretty well Austin if not when we'll do
pretty well I think there were a couple
other candidates around that are gonna
do pretty well and then it will grow
into something that nationally come 2020
is going to be actually more viable than
it was even under guarantee they'll get
someone that's probably younger and more
tech-savvy and whatever it'll be someone
kind of cool and and that they are gonna
then take like they're gonna pull with
some unheard-of number for libertarians
out of national level something like 15%
and we're gonna win electoral votes in
2020 so all good so Tony
we are going to an electoral votes so
I'm with you and I agree but do you see
why I see the danger there to most
danger the the oncoming danger would be
that you'd be pulling all of those votes
from the right and that you end up oh no
no this is not a defense of the right
and I got what you're gonna do here I
look what if you then end up with some
seriously goddamn Lefty good yeah good
sell me on this let's be very clear we
have two choices
option one stay in this slow road to
oblivion which is where we going now or
shake things up and get something happen
here someone asked for the night I was
at an event I was at a sportsman's event
of the night in Suffolk County last
night and the guy said no matter we have
what if you you know take a lot from the
Republican I said I hope I tear them to
pieces
I hope I'd be I'll be it's 5% oh my god
then Republicans will learn their lesson
and have to be Republicans they can't be
Democrat like me more good I hope I hope
that happens let it happen don't care
oh the Democrats get killed get that
smashed good maybe they'll have to care
about civil liberties if libertarians do
well regardless of who's crushed
whoever gets crushed their lesson has to
be learned or they disappear they
disappear we replace them awesome they
don't disappear they get better
there's nothing but good why us crushing
either side or both well I guess
whatever the Republicans so what they'll
be better Republicans if we'd ever say
Democrats so what that'd be better
Democrats doesn't matter yeah I guess
it's the hammer that you ultimately need
it's correct my
would be that then because I believe the
left has gone so far left that the idea
of potentially helping them put in
policies that would be a hundred eighty
degrees from everything you just said
said there that would put in all the de
Blasio stuff that you hate in a city and
all that that I would really really fear
that but you just view it as almost a
necessary evil to look at myself now you
would just you're assuming then that
when this happens people jump on board
they don't they give up mm-hmm New York
is an example of that seventy percent
don't vote the people don't actually
like these ideas yeah they've given up
yeah they think there's no hope so
they've given up guess what here comes
mister hope this opens the door for me
so it happens and 2020 libertarians are
amazing and we crushed the right it does
happen is uh whatever Bernie is the the
president whatever the case may be
all the people have no hope when 2022
comes around for that for that for the
Senate races and for the House races you
will watch libertarians say see what
happened hope and you will watch a
sweeping the power in 22 and then 2024
boom you'll watch the presidency good
good and Democrat to be afraid or they
won't there other thing we know
everything and they'll lose the girls
near the Hillary that was it definitely
we know everything and Trump beat them
mm-hmm or they'll change either way to
win I have no worries
yes I hope you're right I don't care
which one happens crush them both crush
either it's relevant it's the right
answer it's the only way you make the
change whenever you have to have
positive change there has to be some
disruption and we're afraid of
disruption
you can't let's just let people know
there will be disruption let's hold
their hand through it and boom the other
side's awesome yeah alright let's just
knock out a couple policies and then
then I send you back to New York to get
cracking that I do what you do
yeah okay so I think on the drug stuff
marijuana you're for legalization crack
not just legalize of marijuana but also
hemp yeah and I wanted to be regulated
as I say this whole time for farmers
like onions I don't want to write new
rules regulations that take forever I
wanted to take onions cut and paste hemp
marijuana go
the reason why I want it is our farmers
in New York State are struggling
desperately No
so why do I allow that they want you to
grow hemp to grow marijuana they want to
enjoy go ahead do what they want but not
just that people talk about marijuana
and cannabis products is being expensive
and taxed if it's regular like onions
grow in your backyard I don't care corn
your backyard
well how do we sell it attacks the hell
out of it no then we create a black
black market which what we have now all
right
officially you can get medical marijuana
in New York officially you can mm-hmm
one place in New York City and a massive
black market right
so instead like health food store seller
like you what is helpful store palana is
a regulation there's no relation to
health food stores either where all the
deaths from all the health food stores
well G&G deaths or whatever they're all
deaths
none I think I once overdid it would
lead on creatine maybe one light there
we go yes we're hitting the gym a long
time ago so the FDA has killed far more
people yeah then every healthful store
ever created so bring like that so it's
fine put up thing not regular by FDA
good luck whatever I don't care dude out
let's just do a couple other hot-button
ones so guns mm-hmm
we're yet what does that mean well we're
I know you know if people in New York
City itself want far more Jimmy oh yeah
it's fine the same fact it's a big deal
in New York's that you may and may not
know it the SAFE Act came out after
Sandy Hook and it basically made a bunch
of equipment illegal so it made a bunch
of people who own firearms legally
criminals overnight and now they put you
in jail and not just that if you have a
magazine I've I remember the rule right
if your magazine can for the 11 rounds
in it you but you are now a violent
felon according to your state law tip
violent felon that's how bad it is the
safe fact is terrible and now we're
talking with that they have taking guns
for people as I told you their children
in school he says that the child is a
problem child they go take your guns if
you are mentally ill to your guns and
they and New York State includes if
you're transgendered so you don't get to
have guns if you're transgender in your
state I mean it's embarrassing how bad
this thing is it's terrible that has to
be repealed
I can't repeal the law a moment governor
so like I knew was I could begin to
pardon people who were convicted of it
about a thousand people in New York
State have convicted of safe act
um infringement about about a thousand
I'll begin parting them within the first
90 days so we have people in jail in New
York right now who were doing something
completely legally the law changed and
then they were put in jail that's
correct
that is incredible yes that's correct
and it's guns therefore it's evil
yeah remember how the New York state
works New York state works it's evil hit
with a stick that's our first always
first reaction huh what is that it was
thick so we do so yes that's true I
actually met in Jamestown at the first
guy who got a first conviction he's a
three-time coming to felon I think if
I'm mistaken so I'll be in pardoning
when I start to pardon that all the
people know I'm serious stop now what's
gonna happen when I pardon reason why
people don't pardon early is because
what's gonna happen when I partner
hundred people one of them gonna do
something stupid no they're gonna go rob
a liquor store or Austin a car or
whatever do something bad beat your
spouse in certain thing here whatever
thing I do I get it's gonna happen and
when it happens they're gonna blame me
they're gonna say governor sharp you're
an evil guy this liquor store got robbed
because you let a guy out because he was
a he was a violent felon and I'm gonna
say several things I'm the one I don't
care
when I win everyone's gonna hate me I'm
being attacked every day by the assembly
every day by the Senate every day by the
press I'm gonna have a assembly in the
Senate that's completely against me
that's one of a bazillion things won't
care but not just that yes
one guy did something wrong put that guy
in jail for that night people didn't
write that and they got off and our
nation was built on the idea that it
would be better for a guilty person to
go free than an innocent person to be
imprisoned
well good night out I'm okay with that
and when I do that the assembly will see
that I will take the heat for them and
when they see that in 2019 they'll
repeal in 2020 because I've given them
the air cover and on top of that I'm
gonna veto any bill that has any safe
Act enforcement funding gone they won't
bother putting it in because I'll veto
it and they will now have to double down
on it as a separate piece that will
crush them on the right they won't do it
mm-hmm so that means it will not be
enforced and I'll beginning I will have
to be imparting people as they get
arrested
prosecutors love it easy gonna be easy
eviction
cops hate it mm-hmm the cops love that
I'm not enforcing it anymore and they
were happily unforce it it becomes
useless in 2019
gets repealed in 2020 by the way I copy
the same motto for marijuana laws same
model same thing begin begin to pardon
people who are convicted of nonviolent
marijuana possessions stop enforcing it
same idea same concept they see how it
works
2020 repealed yeah it's just incredible
you fall and I follow that's by the way
the the veto and that model is the Gary
Johnson model all right give me give me
one more thing that's an important issue
to you before we were out there's tons
of them that those are good I mentioned
the other one the vaping the duis and
they said also I'm also the biggest idea
though of all of them is the unfunded
mandates we have to localise government
mm-hmm if we take away if we take away
the unfunded mandates now individual
counties can decide important what they
want people say the same thing but Larry
if that happens then I won't get what I
want now you can just show them before
yeah if you like what your county is
doing don't change a thing show up vote
YES on everything and you're good but if
you don't you can change it that's
really the key to libertarianism you
guys has to be involved you might be
yeah and talk to your neighbor and tell
them why you care about a certain policy
or issue you might have to care about
stuff yes but Larry can't someone else
do they couldn't do you now is failing
the other thing is they say all the time
but Larry said calories will make errors
that make mistakes and fail yes but
we're all failing now the state's
bleeding to death I want to follow the
Google model the Google motto says time
said of your time can be used in
whatever you want as long as you're
transparent until but that's what you're
doing
counties do what you want however we
want to vote but transparency if I'm
gonna see what's happening we do that
what happens some fail some succeed but
we then learn what works and what
doesn't we shift and adjust regions
we'll figure out what works for each
region and will actually have
improvement this is disruption that
happens before you have success this
happens in business this happens in
everything happens in life everything so
we do that become a sharing state
sharing economy we change how things
work be it on top of the
that's that's one part the second that
asked me to do is you add what's called
a charitable choice credit for your
taxes what that is is 23 bucks
that would be your tax money going to
the taxman anyway mmm your choice you
can give it to a non-profit if you want
to if you want to it's going out of your
pocket anyway mm-hmm you're gonna go to
a non-profit you can plus another 250 in
your own County so if I were the bucks
of your money into your accounting for
the sake of argument in this area there
are forty thousand people who pay taxes
that's two million possible dollars
voluntary mm-hmm if you want to do it do
it again if you like your government
don't change it yeah don't do it got it
you're good you like it but say you
think is a better way for child care
besides the only government monopoly
which is a disaster there is a better
way for clean roads which government is
a disaster
where's better way a private company now
can Lobby you not the government because
you give the money and the moment you
give the less corruption there is yeah I
love that the more transparent there is
less corruption Ares it allows the
actual counties to begin to privatize as
they want as they see at work they can
make that more or less or shift this is
the beginning part I'm talking about
showing them that there's other ways of
getting things done besides government
and is that a zombie apocalypse on top
of how do I also raise money well what
is the libertarian response to the
zombie apocalypse I don't know I guess
guns I guess yeah so there's another way
of raising money also whichever young
enough also and that is naming rights on
infrastructure right the MTA just in New
York City is over 12 bridges in tunnels
and right now what we've done in New
York State is we've named one of our
bridges after the Cuomo family it's
called the mero como bridge now we have
which bridge is that it's what happens
in your rush peppers and now it is now
this the Imperial bridge of the imperial
family so now that has to go instead
let's let's lease out any rights it
could be the Verizon bridge the Sprint
bridge the Staples bridge the Home Depot
bridge I don't care you pick the the
person who wants it right they come he
wants it no now they do this for all
ready for stadiums mmm they pay 10 20 30
miles a year for something used half a
year this is a bridge they could choose
every day you name gets mentioned a
hundred times at least every morning
afternoon during rush hour on every
window station in a sick
ten million person metro area you're
telling me companies that pay literally
billions of dollars in marketing every
year water behind a million dollars in a
bridge but here's a rule no tolls actual
break for people and they control
maintenance if they control maintenance
guess what no more corruption in the
maintenance industry anymore because now
Sprint's paying for not the government
no more closing lanes at the deal
closing lanes in the VW bridge goes away
Sprint's I can't put up with it there's
potholes Sprint's I can put up with it
they'll fire you or sue you yeah
these are different ideas that people do
we have an Erie Canal in New York State
it's about five hundred and some odd
miles of every canal we can name the
locks it's about three dozen locks named
locks all differ idea is there's so many
ways of raising money and changing how
we look at this and they're not perfect
by any means but the conversations we
need to be having to ship this idea that
the only way to civilization is taxation
it is the only way it's a way it's not
the only way there are other options
available and people just don't get it
you open this up I breeze like this of
all time they love it they eat it up you
guys ready I like that idea let me try
that
someone's gonna be tried this is what we
want to do we shift the way New York
State were runs and the rest of the
nation will follow if I just beat the
Republican everyone will hear what I
have to say I've been every TV show in
the country they will hear what I have
to say they'll hear this they'll start
telling their people they'll start
copying this campaign has the most
possibility for impact than any other
campaign in 2018 and here's what I
promise you if I raise two million
dollars I'm the governor
it's that simple two million bucks on
the governor done well I've enjoyed this
conversation I think you got the right
set of ideas and I look forward to
seeing what happens good and now I'm
gonna send people to your website
because I assume you got it don't I
Larry sharp calm Larry show up with an e
the e stands for electable now I know
you're really running because he even
pimped out the website I'm selling Larry
sharp calm
[Music]
you